hey everyone it is my first time at PI
data so I'm excited to be here yeah all
right I'll go ahead and get started just
like to give you an idea of who I am so
you believe me as I'm talking to you so
I am leading the curriculum development
at Metis I'm also an instructor there I
primarily focus both in deep learning in
general as well as ethics in data
science my sort of focus and Ganz is
maybe about a year to old in addition to
that I work with a local nonprofit Teva
tech leaving free workshops around here
I also wanted to say so Justin blender
is a student of mine he graduated I
believe four months ago and so this is
what you'll see today is actually a
continuation of a student is his final
project and so what happened is as
students tend to do an extremely
ambitious like idea for his final
project and just like because of time
and because of like he had literally
just started working in data science
three months before he wasn't able to
fully see it to its end and so what I've
done is added I'll show you
you'll see the whole thing but I added
one relatively new normalization
technique and then sort of what the
title of the talk is about a process
that allows us to get conditioned Gans
based on multi-label data and so those
are the things that were missing when
the project as he sort of like finished
it up a few months ago and and yeah I'll
show you sort of like the final product
unfortunately Justin can't be here I
wish he could so I wanted to signpost a
little bit like I said this is my first
time at PI data I don't really know I
don't have a great feel for where
everybody's at I don't know if we're all
like tensorflow
experts like writing code that gets
accepted nips or if we're sort of like
new to all of this and so this is like
where I've been aiming and if if it's a
little bit off let's just adjust it so I
like I want feedback I want to make
as interactive as possible it's a
tutorial teaching is what I do so so
hopefully we can figure that out so I'm
aiming for people who basically like
understand the fundamentals of deep
learning so you could probably explain
maybe like with some efforts these ideas
backpropagation stochastic gradient
descent maybe like our familiar with
like common loss functions and different
tools that we actually used to build
deep learning models if not there's
gonna be a fairly quick review which of
course we can slow down there's like a
whole room of white board if we want to
we want to talk about this stuff I'm
also sort of aiming for people who have
used recent deep learning packages so
we'll be doing all of this in Kerris
which i think is the most accessible one
I actually I might have been that I'm a
little bit frustrated hi tours is also
quite accessible but yeah we'll be using
a one of the really modern packages so
if you're unfamiliar with that there
might be a little bit of a learning
curve there and again just like stop me
if if you get to a line of code or
something that seems unfamiliar or
difficult to explain can you guys show
up hands like how many people have built
a jitter that adversarial network in
anything here and it's okay okay yeah so
just like a handful I think I guess so
I'll try to make sure I'm providing
something for everybody folks who are
new to this idea of what again is I mean
folks we're really interesting some new
techniques so by the end of the talk
you know if we're all we all accomplish
our goals I want everybody to be able to
do these things so the basics are
understand and explain what's important
about generative adversarial networks so
what makes them different from other
networks what makes them go what are the
parts that if they were missing it would
break I'm also going to be giving you
boilerplate code that hopefully you'll
understand well enough to at least adapt
it for new purposes so maybe you have a
data set of your own that you want to
use on this it's not the data set that
I'm teaching I'm hopefully you'll have
enough understanding to actually be able
to do that
so we'll be talking a little bit about
state-of-the-art techniques and Gans I
don't necessarily expect everyone to
understand or be able to derive spectral
normalization by the end but but I will
expose you to a few things and the big
thing I want for on that end is when you
leave here that you're at least better
and able to do your own independent
exploration so if you see a new concept
you know there's three months left in
the year who knows what's gonna come out
and so if you if one of those new
developments happens hopefully you'll be
better and able to do your own
exploration like what that is maybe
building building it out in your own
code maybe looking at other people's
implementations of something new and
making sense out of it so does that does
that sound good does anybody does that
sound off like significantly authorize
it it's cool all right so what we're
gonna do now is a deep learning review
and this is something that I mean you
could have a semester-long course over
this we're gonna try to do it and I
don't know 10 15 minutes and so maybe
less than that even so this is gonna be
fairly quick if anybody is like
completely lost please let me know
because we I can like absolutely take my
time this is absolutely one of my
favorite topics to teach I don't have
that many slides on it but we can always
add material so these sort of common
structure of all deep learning models is
a chain of differentiable functions and
so it might not be obvious but you can
see I'm starting with this is sort of
the common nomenclature for deep
learning models and so X is gonna be our
input data we've got it just a variable
here but it's we typically batch it
together so like a series of images
series of rows whatever your data looks
like and so that there with the WX plus
B that's just what we call an affine
transformation like a linear
transformation so this is if you've ever
had a linear algebra class this is the
sort of basic building block of that
class and so so if you you can see here
we're just using these building blocks
ephes are just like general function
to build our hidden layers and those are
the h's h0 h1 and we'll we'll build in
of them in could be anywhere I think
there's no like dividing line for a deep
model but typically in is a few to
hundreds many of the modern models have
hundreds dozens and dozens of layers and
so the important thing to understand
about deep learning the way it works and
an especially important thing for the
tutorial coming up is that all this is
is a chain of differentiable functions
so we don't really care what F is like
eventually the details matter but just
in general we're starting out F can be
anything as long as it's generally
differentiable and so so what that means
we can actually look at this from the
traditional application perspective sort
of like where deep learning started
where we have tabular data you might
have seen presentations on that
traditional application here where you
have like rows maybe a panda's data
frame with rows of data you have your
features that your input that would be X
and then you're predicting a y and Y can
be a number if you're doing regression
it can be a classification but the
really cool thing about deep learning is
because it's because that first
definition that it's just a chain of
differentiable functions is so loose we
actually set it up to do some really
impressive quite different things from
that tabular data to prediction so one
thing that we can do is image to text
you might have seen those automated
captioning systems they're really really
cool that's completely different from
that traditional application if you
think about it um image to image there's
a few of these super resolution is one
of them that's really cool where you
take an image essentially like add
pixels guess what those pixels would be
if the image had been downsized what
we're gonna be doing with Ganz's is sort
of even a step below this which is going
from nothing or or a random data
distribution to images we're just going
to be generating images randomly and and
this flexible structure of deep learning
is really what allows us
to do that so that's that's like a
general it's a really high-level
abstract point but it is like quite
important for understanding how this
works so what are the important
ingredients so we we're sort of building
this extremely like tall or deep network
here and then we're going to use these
two tools to actually make that useful
so stochastic gradient descent is not
limited to deep learning actually
essentially many if not if not nearly
all of the data science models that you
use can be adapted to use gradient
descent and so so yeah it's a general
principle that actually just allows you
you define a loss function that measures
performance in such a stochastic
gradient descent just finds the
adjustment to the parameters of your
model that minimizes that loss function
so if loss function is if the higher it
goes it's bad if we use stochastic
gradient descent to minimize that loss
function we're gonna be improving things
and so so once we do that then the whole
ball game is no longer it's no longer
the details of like setting up your
model or pre-processing by hand it's
really setting up this chain of
functions and your loss function so that
as stochastic gradient descent minimizes
that loss function you get something
useful so it's a very different sort of
approach to traditional data science
approaches where if you've ever done you
did computer vision before maybe like
2010 it was a lot of pre-processing by
hand you know a lot of these like
setting things up very very carefully
and it might seem like a totally
different world now we're really we just
set up a deep learning model who could
there were that could theoretically do
all of those transformations that we
used to do by hand it could learn them
and then we just let it learn whatever
transformations are the best so so yeah
that stick has a gradient descent back
propagation is just the the piece of the
puzzle that allows us to do gradient
descent at each layer it is literally
the chain rule of calculus it's just an
algorithm for the
yeah and it applies it to many layers
yes it's not necessarily it is it's it's
not convex is the only difference is
stochastic gradient descent can apply to
extremely non convex functions and for
one there's there's a lot of people I
don't have them I don't have the
citations off top of my head but you can
show fairly straightforwardly that deep
learning models are necessarily highly
non convex so they have tons of local
minima and it's like a huge problem and
yeah so part of part of like getting
these things to work is setting it up so
that hey your local minima czar pretty
good and be you don't have to get stuck
in the bad ones but yeah you can
actually so an example of a convex
optimization problem is support vector
machines many implementations use SGD as
part of that question I don't know I
know I have code somewhere in my
computer actually implementing support
vector machines in tensorflow
using tensorflow stochastic Reena so
it's not an efficient implementation but
it's just demonstrating that you can use
that and I know that there are people
online that have that as well cool any
other questions it's sort of like a very
high level look at deep learning but I
sort of like want us to have these
concepts sort of be comfortable with
them before we get into the nitty-gritty
of what gans are mm-hmm cool cool yeah
so that's all of deep learning really
quick uh-huh
yeah so we'll get into the code a little
bit more to I think I set this up to be
like a little bit of a loose set of
slides so that I can get a feel for
where everybody's at and then we can dig
into the code we can add things if if
anybody has questions okay we're gonna
talk about Gans in general but before I
really dig deep into what Gans are
specifically I
want to talk about convolutional
classifiers so I mentioned earlier that
computer vision has changed drastically
in the last couple decades this right
here convolutional classifiers is
exactly why this is the tool that sort
of like revolutionized that that field
and so what we're doing with
convolutional classifiers is we're
setting up that chain of differentiable
functions and a convolution is just a
differentiable function that learns a
feature or mapping and so that's what
this image if you've if you've looked at
any like image recognition and deep
learning papers or blog post you've seen
something like this and so what's
happening is we sort of at the very left
we have our input which is the robot
image and in this so what convolutions
do I wasn't planning to go into the math
but we can talk about it a little bit if
somebody wants to we're essentially
passing that feature over the entire
image and so whenever that feature is
present in the image it activates
whenever it's not president it isn't
active often it's somewhere in between
and so the important thing is that you
see those layers there like several
sheets of paper or something that's just
to signify that we're learning several
feature Maps so we might have one for
vertically oriented edges one for
horizontally oriented edges and so so
what we're doing is we're sort of
setting this up so that the network the
deep Learning Network can learn these
features that's the first step and then
we're actually using either sampling or
pooling we will talk more a little bit
we'll talk a little bit more later about
what those mean but once we learn those
features were actually summarizing the
image in terms of the height and width
we're shrinking it using sampling and
pooling so that it actually is forced to
combine those features into bigger parts
essentially until it gets down to that
hole that it's able to make that
prediction on
um yeah and so so accomplishment
pacifiers typically or always I guess
necessarily because they're classify
your in in some classification vector so
if this is your typical classification
problem where you have if you've ever
seen like the digits classification you
have ten possible numbers it's a vector
of ten probabilities that's the output
of this model if you've looked at image
net what all the the fancy Hot Shot
models are trained on you got a vector
of a thousand classes and a thousand
probabilities so it looks like let's
look at a little bit closer actually
what's happening here so this is this is
a different way of looking at that same
set up so this I actually didn't mention
it earlier a lot of my images I'm I have
the citations and the slides but they're
either typically they're either from
Sholay or in Goodfellas books so this
one's from Shelley's book I really
really like this way of thinking about
convolutional filters so that's our
image there on the bottom it's like
what's happening is the network is
passing these filters over it and saying
like that first one is just like this
weird like curved edge and so that
filter will become active every time it
sees a curved edge and then we have that
like downward sloping edge and then we
have maybe this like black triangle in
the middle and so all of those filters
are essentially telling the network all
right this is where this feature is in
the in the image and the the utility of
sampling or pooling to shrink your
height or your yeah pixel height and
pixel width as you go through the
network um the utility of that is it
forces it to summarize those sub parts
into parts and those parts into even
bigger constituent parts and eventually
you get that process down to a hole that
you can make a prediction on and you can
sort of see what this looks like
whenever we look at feature
visualization which is mmm I don't know
what happen there
all right uh so so yeah I've been
talking about these convolutional
filters one way to think about actually
what's happening here is to take a
filter and ask alright what input image
would make that filter the most active
and so this is sort of like a cartoon
representation of like a sort of
rightward curving line but you can
imagine what it would look like if we've
said what is the image that maximizes
that filter and it would might be one of
these that has a bunch of rightward
curving lines on it into that that gives
us an idea of what that filters looking
for that one's just looking for that
texture we can actually put those put
those edges together to get a series of
edges and that's that's what this
illustration is calling a texture you
can Protection's together for patterns
and so this is from left to right as
where we go from input image down
through that deep network and as we go
to the right I don't know what's that
way hmm
right as we go to the right we're
getting close to that prediction so it's
it's pulling more and more whole data
out of that image in preparation of that
prediction and if I can zoom in on this
yeah this is this comes from it really
cool i I've sort of hinted at it but a
really cool demonstration how this works
but in the bottom right you can actually
see this is from a real network it's
actually like learning dogs eventually
and so those are like cute little puppy
bases and that's like the image that
that's the input image that most
activates those filters that are closely
rid of related to predicting dog and so
you can sort of see like what it's
looking for when you think in terms of
that and that gives us a better idea of
how it works all right so that is a very
it's a very quick overview of how
convolutional classifiers work does it
have questions about that or anything
that feels like uncertain or
I'm comfy maybe so maybe if you've never
heard of a convolutional classifier this
feels like a whole lot I'll tell you
like I was building successful image
recognition models and deep learning
before I actually understood any of this
so it's not an essential part to
understand it but I think it helps a lot
so we can you've got the code you can
actually just put the code together that
does this whether you sort of understand
or appreciate that process and it still
works so so yeah I guess what I'm saying
is fear not if it feels uncomfortable
but if it does and you want to talk
about it I wanted to open it up all
right so we're we're ultimately working
towards generating images I've gotten as
far as talking about how to classify
images that's kind of the opposite so
now let's think about how generating
images would work with these same puzzle
pieces so we've talked about using
convolutions plus what I called pooling
or subsampling to shrink an image this
is sort of a visual representation of
what it looks like to actually use
convolutions plus the opposite of that
either up sampling or what is
technically not correctly called
deconvolution in Kerris we call it
convolution transpose but we actually
use those to progressively grow an image
so essentially what we're doing is we're
taking this process of image
classification and running it in Reverse
so where we're starting this's this is
still our input but rather than
shrinking the image as it goes down
towards that hole we're actually going
to be increasing it we're actually gonna
be blowing it up so here we'll talk a
little bit more about what that input is
or what that means but we're just gonna
give it a random noise vector of it
could be zeros and ones it could just be
values drawn from a bell curve so here
we've got a hundred lengths vector and
we're going to reshape that and then run
a convolution on it over and over again
and if we up sample between convolution
runs we actually get a progress
larger image that we're forcing to learn
how to generate a plausible replica of
the training data so again we'll see
we'll see in code I feel like some
people it helps out these visuals so I
wanted to make sure I have them in there
sometimes it's a little bit easier to
see in the code what's happening so see
yeah just a recap so we've talked about
convolutional classifiers we've talked
about convolutional generators really
really really briefly we direct
convolutional generators so gains what
gains do sort of their value is putting
those together in a in a very useful way
one way historically to do that is
actually just to skip the gain process
and just have what's called an auto
encoder something that takes in an image
summarizes it down to a vector and then
blows it up and so that's you can think
about that as our like zero starting
point and that has some drawbacks that
we can go into if if people went to but
I didn't include here so Ganz work this
way we sort of set up these two teams
this D here this D function is called is
for the discriminator and then G is for
the generator so if you want to sort of
attach these two images this will be G
here the thing that's blowing up a
vector into an image and then this will
be D the thing that's taking an image
and shrinking it down to a useful vector
so the way we set these up we set them
up in sort of a game do they play
against each other where the first task
for the discriminator is to take that X
sample from the training data and just
learn to classify every training data
image as one it's a really easy task you
know alone it could do that perfectly as
you might guess it could just guess one
for everything so it becomes challenging
when we built the generator the other
half of this which is we're asking it to
generate plausible images from the
training
and then then you can sort of think
about the discriminative task is getting
both this original image which is on the
right and then this generated image on
the left and then we're asking the
discriminator to say like all right
which of these is real and which of
these is fake so now the generators are
the the discriminators job gets a lot
harder it has to tell the difference
between these two images these are
selected to be it's a little bit easy to
tell which one the right one is a little
bit more pixelated I think but you can
see how it's not a trivial task now it's
no longer there's a challenge there and
so so yeah so we have this input noise
vector Z which G actually uses to
generate that image and then we have an
X sampled from the training data and
then D tries to make that the images
from the generator that's G of Z near
zero and then the images from the
training data near one all right so
that's like yeah this is sort of box
ology here maybe that's not the most
helpful so I just want to like take a
pause I'm talking about networks a
little bit and just like talk about like
what this task is so I mentioned that
autoencoders just try to recreate images
they try to summarize it and then
recreate it if you've ever done
principal component analysis it's
basically the same thing as what an auto
encoder is doing a generator is doing
something fundamentally different from
what an auto encoder does a generator
isn't taking an image and then like
summarizing it so that it can recreate
it a generator is trying to reproduce
that training dataset in a meaningful
way so let's think about the cypher data
set has anybody use this cipher our data
set before it's it's a very cute data
set it's 32 pixels by 32 pixels we'll
use it in the zebra notebook section of
this a little bit later but the nice
thing about is it's small enough so that
you can run things like in the amount of
time that it takes like I don't know go
get a coffee or finish the sentence um
so this is a frog from that data set and
so you might think about what if your
task was the generators task of fooling
somebody and making them think that you
the date the thing that you draw the 32
by 32 pixels that you draw is from the
same set of data that that image is from
how would you do it like what color
would you make the Frog if you had to do
that
does anybody know excuse me yeah what
color would you make your frogs if you
had to generate frogs on the training
data Green would be a good guess yeah I
think Green is a great guess this one's
a little bit Brown I think so maybe
greenish Brown I think most frogs are
probably gonna be on the ground which so
we might do like a greenish mostly Brown
though background with like some green
specks in it that might be a frog
drawing process but if you think about
what the generator does task is though
the generator is gonna get hundreds of
these and so looking at that same data
set you can see our friend here let's
think about like what that
discriminators task is gonna be so if
you perfectly replicate this image if
you get really really good at drawing
these like 32 by 32 pixels and then the
generator sees your image and a bunch of
them and then it sees this set of images
do you think it'll be easy for the
discriminator to tell what's real versus
what's fake could you like what if you
put yourself on the other side if you
were the discriminator and I drew I drew
a hundred of these and then you're
comparing it to a hundred of these and
you had to guess all right which of
these are the real images and which of
them gonna fake what do you think your
accuracy would be I don't I don't think
so if we can perfectly replicate it
though if we could just like copy this
like download onto a thumb drive and
then upload
every time the discriminator asks for an
image excuse me I could I could get it
right every time except for once and
here's how is I would say every image
that looks exactly like this was
generated by the generator that
memorized that image and then every
image that isn't like that is from the
training data and the only one I would
miss is that one in the top left hand
corner because it looks exactly like the
memorized image so do you see like
that's that's it's that sort of like
simplest understanding of the task
actually like the generator would lose
every time so what the generator
actually needs to do is it needs to be
able to generate hundreds of these that
look like they're from the same set of
data as this so the generator is not
memorizing images and just reproducing
them it's it's actually learning the
entire distribution of that training
data I mean it's trying to reproduce
that distribution and that's that's a
hard task like I'm saying distribution
it's sort of like a mathematical term
here but what we mean by that is the
world like we actually like these are
just taken by real people of real frogs
in the real world and so the generator
is trying to understand how that world
works and generate images like that
which is quite the task
so yeah it's learning that distribution
of the training data so what that means
what we get from that that's like it's
an abstract point at first but what we
get from that is something SuperDuper
cool so we get this like truly
meaningful understanding of the training
data an autoencoder
like the JPEG compression algorithm is
an auto encoder it just like it just
shrinks an image and then it blows it
back up it doesn't understand how the
world works but if we do it right a
generator really does and so what this
is this is from one of the early deep
convolutional gain papers what this is
is they took so in that first column
they took all
the men with glasses in this in the data
said that we're sorry I'll back up this
is all from the celeb data set the celeb
a data set that and that's what we're
gonna be using here in a little bit and
so in this paper in this deep
convolutional gand paper what they did
is they took all of the men with glasses
and I just like averaged up the vector
that was used for those and they did all
of them in without glasses for that and
what you can do for that generator is
that you can actually use this vector
math and you can say like take the start
take the starting vector the mainland
subtract the main without glasses and
then add woman with glasses and what it
actually learns is that okay there's
this direction that's a gender and if I
go in that direction I'm going along
this like male-female spectrum whatever
that means and then there's this glasses
spectrum there's this with and without
glasses spectrum and if I travel along
that spectrum that I get people with and
without glasses and so if I if I take
man with glasses subtract man and an ADD
woman with glasses then I get woman with
glasses yes ooh it makes it easier
that's a great question
so if anybody didn't hear we were asked
like if if this only works because it's
cropped maybe this paper only would have
worked if it was cropped in general like
one one really really recent paper and
one that actually inspired the second
stuff that we're about to get into I
think the act like the sort of hashtag
er is big Gann bi G GaN they use the
original image net data set which is
just like things out in the wild so
nothing is like very tightly cropped
like this it's like real live images and
does really well like shockingly well so
so yeah it doesn't have to be cropped
but I cropped the images that we're
gonna use and makes it a heck of a lot
easier but yeah so this is this vector
math seems a little bit hokey maybe if
you've never seen it before anybody
who's
done word embeddings though has anybody
seen word embedding math yeah this is
the exact same ideas word embedding this
so so it can be pretty cool so yeah all
right so we've got Ganz hopefully under
our belt at least we feel a little more
comfortable with them I'm the really
important thing that I wanted us to
understand is like what it means
actually learn this distribution
we're like learning meaningful qualities
about like how these images are
generated rather than just how to
stupidly reproduce them so I've got two
more topics I wanted to cover in the
slides we won't go into detail on these
but rather than switching from slides to
notebook to slides in a notebook I
wanted to just like at least point these
out before we dive into the notebooks
and then we can be in the notebooks for
the rest of the session okay so the
first one is this wacky idea called
Lipschitz continuity anyway like watch
the Rugrats as a kid like Lipschitz
always makes anything of that so it's a
it's an annoyingly complex idea but like
we can sort of simplify it as
understanding so the Lipschitz constant
is like if you have a function it's the
maximum rate of change of the function
so I mean support so does anybody who
knows the the definition of raela the
rectified linear unit you just shout it
out yeah so I'm getting some hand
motions and the hand motion is basically
this right so it's it's roughly f of X
roughly it's exactly it's going to X
comma X 0 and C go to 0 else all right
and so this is like we would draw our
origin right there let me get a litany
derp Sigma excuse me it doesn't really
use it with Sigma
that oh maybe actually you're probably
right um yeah I was yeah just using the
general function but yeah um I don't
know that for sure but I'm sure you're
right to the point the reason I do this
up here is that we can just like think
really quickly about for some symbol
functions what the Lipschitz constant is
so what's the maximum rate of change of
this function one yeah so so the rate of
change here is just one and so that's
the maximum that's a Maxima never gets
so for functions like that for this one
it's like quite easy trying to do that
with like 10 H and it gets a little bit
trickier and so so all all the Lipschitz
constant and talking about this concept
does is it gives us a vocabulary to talk
about like how quickly derivatives
change and if we can define a sort of
limit on the derivative of a function or
the gradient of a function as long as
we're using it so this relates to a
problem that's encountered in a lot of
gang cases where it often is like the
discriminators job is sort of
objectively a little bit easier than the
generators job the discriminator is just
comparing these images often like
anecdotally like you can make a really
simple small discriminator that beats
these like huge generators that have
tons of parameters that can sort of
tweak to get slightly better and so
often there's there was a suspicion by
the authors of this paper that i think
yeah i linked to it in the notebooks i
meant a link to it here but i forgot but
the problem that they were suspecting is
that in many cases the discriminator
essentially becomes perfect it's it just
figures out the generators game and and
there's no way the generator can win and
in that extreme case if you think about
it like what's the gradient for the
generator if it's never going to win and
there's nothing it can do to change that
its gradient is flat so there's no way
for it to improve the
no way like way to climb up the mountain
to improve it's just like a straight
wall and so what spectral normalization
does is it actually is a normalization
method that constrains that Lipschitz
constant and so it says like alright
we're gonna make we're gonna normalize
the weights so that there's no way that
they could ever be greater than one or
the the Lipschitz constant of that
function could be greater than one so
yeah it's like it's actually like a
fairly when you look at it at that like
high level it's a fairly straightforward
idea I implemented that coding Kerris
there's a couple others that have it
implemented I wrote my own
that's like fairly simple um it's like
one of the more simple ways to do it so
we can actually look at that code here
in a minute this is the big new
development that I added in and and this
is actually what I was talking about to
whomever asked if you had to crop images
so this is one of the big additions of
that big and paper that allowed them to
really successfully generate image net
images so the last sort of like advanced
scan topic that we'll talk about really
quickly is conditional Gans so there's
this general observation that goes back
like years from like Ian Goodfellow that
you can use classes whenever you're
generating these images you can use
classes defiant to add signal to that to
the process of learning what the
distribution of the data is I mean so
you can think about it as maybe maybe an
hour let me back up to the Frog one I
don't have an image up here with all of
the different classes but in Syfy
there's ten classes there's frogs
airplanes trucks cars cats dogs deer and
there's a couple I'm probably missing a
couple but the generator before it
starts doesn't know that there's ten
groups of things it for all it knows
there could be a thousand groups of
things there's actually a companion data
set called sIFR 100 that actually has a
hundred groups of things the generator
doesn't know that distribution ahead of
time
of the classes and so at minimum you can
sort of imagine that giving the
generator that really useful information
saying that like alright here are ten
classes and this one belongs to that
class as its as its trying to generate
images that could actually like help it
quite a bit and so so both the generator
and the discriminator benefit from the
extra data you get quicker in terms of
the wall clock time learning you
actually have to do a couple more steps
in training so the like the training
process takes a little bit longer but if
you like measure on your watch learning
happens quite a bit quicker and the cool
thing is we don't have to do that
complicated like vector math that we
were doing with a man with glasses won't
move buses anymore we can just say like
flip this bit upwards and then now we
have a person with like dark hair or
light hair and so I wanted to just like
really really briefly go over the way I
implemented this in the in the model and
then you'll see the code in a little bit
so here are two classifying auxilary
classifying gaen schemes the first one
was originally limited to single class
classification so it's the AC can
architecture there's a really good paper
on it's really really common in the
field and fairly recently there was it's
not actually it hasn't been that popular
but there's been in addition to this
called the V AC for versatile auxilary
classifier game and so what they did is
they actually built like a third network
so we're talking about Ganz's to unite
works they just like added this
classifier network over there and just
trained that totally separately and so
what that does is it allows you to it
frees you up from single class
classification to allow you to do
anything that you can run classification
on it can be multi class it can be multi
class binary may be multi glass binary
plus a regression if you wanted to and
so that's that's been really handy in my
work just because like the single class
classification is great for a lot of the
standard data
sets but it's a little bit frustrating
when you want to classify things like
with these like interesting like
non-traditional labels and so like the
celeb a data set for instance has binary
labels many binary labels and so what
what I've ended up doing is almost
exactly the they're the versatile ast
can but I've actually combines the
classify on the discriminator and so all
I've done is just separated them at the
very last layer so in essence it sort of
has that same contour of the three
separate models here but in truth it's
it's one model for the discriminating
classifier except with a very final
layer alright and before we get into
code I wanted to show everybody some
results so this is the input training
data of celeb a you'll notice like I
cropped them but you'll also notice that
with this crop you still get quite a bit
of like interesting variation and get
some people whose faces are totally to
the side they're all pretty lined up and
so here's some of the results that are
generated and maybe maybe you're far
enough away that they look really good
these are these are trained on just like
the cheapest GPU that you can buy on AWS
so they haven't been turned on like the
big Google teepee use yet but you think
we actually get like quite good results
and they're fairly significantly better
than the the way reduced ones from just
a couple years ago they're more detailed
than these I haven't trained them as
long so we have a little bit more
artifacting but but you can sort of see
some of the benefits there and the
really nice benefit is without the
matrix math we can at a really large
scale replicate the the binary label
manipulation yeah to generate it this
takes about two seconds to generate
there's this set of 100 images probably
less time that's just like ballparking
it this trained for 10 hours and it
about an hour in epoch so yeah this is
this is just 10 epochs of training which
gives you an idea of how like how fresh
this network is they can train quite a
bit further yeah I wanted to show you
manipulating these bits so this one you
can actually see if I flip back and
forth this is just the random the label
vector is completely randomized some
people are smiling some people are not
smiling if we change it so the right
side is all smiling and the left side is
all founding you get a pretty
significant if not if a little bit
difficult to notice change so you can
pick out some of the ones on the left
that are smiling and they're definitely
not smiling in the second one so here's
the first so maybe maybe look at changed
and then we can just like really easily
arbitrarily change them to not smiling
the second one is easier
this is eyeglasses I'm so almost
nobody's wearing eyeglasses here so we
put glasses on everybody what was the
next one bangs bangs are another really
easy one to tell so now we're giving
everybody things and yeah so there's
like this forty label so we can do this
with a bunch of labels so yeah that's
just demonstrating what putting all
these pieces together can do so so
thanks and well before we get to the
notebook part of it does anyone have
questions though yes yes that's a great
question so it's called adversarial
because it's actually the reason it
works is here we've got the
discriminator and the generator working
against each other
and yet it only works if they are like
relatively evenly matched they don't
have to be like exactly like the
discriminator always wins basically but
yeah yes yes exactly
great question you'll see it in the code
because this is actually how I set up
the code but we have a random we have
two parts to generate every face here we
have a noise vector that's just sort of
like random noise and then we have the
feature vector which is all the binary
features and if we fix that noise vector
for every single image then we can
essentially regenerate that same image
and if we only change the feature vector
then we can say like what would this
person look like with bangs or with a
bald head or something yeah great
question yes yeah for that one it's kind
of like wide open so in that big game
paper image and they actually go through
using a bunch of distributions typically
it's normal
maybe it's uniform sometimes but they
used a binomial so sort of like randomly
flood bits and actually found that that
one works better and like almost nobody
uses that as an input distribution but
yeah it's it can be essentially anything
yeah I think yeah you right there yes
that's a really really good question so
I don't know if we have time to get too
deep into it so there's there's a couple
methods prior to spectral normalization
that have been really helpful for Ganz
and so one of them has been gradient
penalties and then weight clipping are
you talking about either of those are
you talk about gradient clipping
specifically yeah so gradient clipping
is a specific technique honestly to like
make it to make deep learning work
numerically because the gradients can
tend to sort of like vanish even in like
well-designed networks and so gradient
clipping sort of makes sure that we
never get like a huge spike in the
gradient or something like that that we
can't take the derivative of but yeah
gradient penalties
wait clipping essentially tried to
accomplish this indirectly and so if
you've seen anything on like the
Wasserstein Gann the water sign loss
applied to gain all those that simply
had these great and penalties in order
to work and this is just a
computationally efficient way to
accomplish that directly of making sure
the gradient doesn't exceed a certain
value yeah I think that's a really good
question so now that I know of
yeah for like generative like NLP works
actually quite a bit differently you're
you're still estimating the training
distribution but you're estimating like
word transitions typically or like you
essentially in in effect estimating like
like a really long Markov chain of like
these ten words preceded like what next
one and you're sort of estimating that
distribution and so so yeah NLP like
recurrent neural networks have been
doing that for a while like directly and
really really well but yeah I don't know
like any of these ligand techniques
specifically for NLP yeah you will take
a couple more questions and then we can
start on the notebooks yeah I think your
hand up yeah oh no you right there in
the striped shirt no you turning I
thought I saw your hand raised
oh no you like him okay nevermind yeah
so do you want to tell everybody what
mode collapses distribution find the
mode and keep sort of generating or
there and do well without having lots of
variation so it fits like generating
celebrities here we see lots of
different skin color but maybe a little
you do a lot easier like I'll just
generate lots of like maybe like white
males for example because there's more
different to the bad my training set
yeah that's yeah that's a great question
so moat collapse is like the bane of
generative adversarial networks it's
super challenging and so yeah that's
roughly what it is is so often you can
think that like it's it's trying to
generate a lot of different mode is just
sort of like you think of it as these
like ideals or these like you might have
like this kind of person and a lot of
like people that are similar maybe like
old white guy is a really big mode here
but typically the modes are a little bit
more specific than that
I mean you can you can see it you can
imagine a generator that sort of has two
or three of those models for images that
it's trying to generate at the same time
and then stochastic gradient descent so
it's like okay if you go next I closer
to either of those you're gonna improve
and it essentially just picks one and it
has to combine that gradient improvement
for both of those modes and so typically
for moat collapse you get like faces
that really look like they're a mash-up
of two or three modes like on top of
each other it looks really ugly
I know spectral normalization is
supposed to help out with that
significantly in my experience it does I
don't have a great explanation as to why
I don't see how that would be related
directly to the slope of the gradient
but but also yeah
in general this beyond just like
constraining the gradient spectral
normalization is a regularization
technique so it constrains like what the
discriminator can do it holds it back so
that independently of the gradient might
be helpful okay yeah so let's get
started on the notebooks really quickly
I want to do at least show everybody
we've got about thirty five more minutes
and I want to have time to open it up
for questions again so I put this URL up
here and that's where actually like
everything is located for
so you can follow that as lesson links
for the notebooks and before anybody
like downloads it and runs it I wanted
to show everybody a couple caveats so
you'll notice that the link to the
lesson goes straight to this collab dot
researched at Google who's used that
before a lot of people awesome well if
you if you've ever like been hard up for
GPU cache this is your friend for now at
least it's it's free GPU access and so
it's one reason I linked to this is
because I a lot of this is only
interesting if you can do it at scale on
a GPU doesn't really work that
interestingly on a CPU so after you load
that first notebook you can go to change
runtime type and you can say alright
Google let me use your free GPUs and
it's literally that easy so yeah now
we're we're all gonna be running on
something that would take like a couple
thousand bucks to buy and install on our
own computers so that's cool um the
other thing is that in some of the later
notebooks let me let me back up you're
here
yeah particularly this lesson 3 so if
you wanted to skip ahead or look at
these this one is gonna have you
download a couple gigabytes of data and
even this one if you like haven't used
Karis a--'s dataset package it'll have
you download data as well and the thing
I want to serve like red flag for
everybody is that you absolutely under
no circumstances should all do this at
the same time unlike the Wi-Fi that
we're all using because it just won't
work
like nobody's Wi-Fi will work and so I
if you want to run this notebook I've
like put it on CLAB to sort of like
force you into using it on google
servers that they can sort of distribute
the load intelligently and so so when
you get to that second one if we like
end up running out of time or whatever I
put a note here but in order to get this
to run correctly you'll just want to
uncomment these and then run them and
that'll download the data the the
cropped version of this lebay data so
that I put together just for you it's a
couple gigabytes that takes like two
minutes to run okay so that's all the
prep we need to sort of like get these
notebooks up and running has anyone had
trouble like finding the website does
that work for everybody cool and I think
you might need a Google account or a
Google Drive account to use this collab
service so I apologize if I'm forcing
you to do that and you didn't want to oh
yeah also I you will get if you change
it to GPU
like I said um you'll typically get this
it's like a warning we're gonna run it
anyway so the very first thing is just
installing a display package we'll see
the fruits of that labor in a second
yeah we're just like running apt and
pipped install those two things all
right
now that's done we're gonna we're gonna
pull in all of our pile up stuff and yet
so now we're in just like standard
Jupiter notebook land which at PI data I
expect everybody to be relatively
familiar let me know if you have any
questions about the interface oh also
I'll turn on I'll turn on a key caster
in case like anybody wants to know like
what is happening so you can see like as
I run through here the shortcuts are a
little bit different in collab so yeah
your escape a doesn't work anymore but
some of the other ones do alright so so
yeah like I said we're gonna be running
this on sai far I've got a lot of the
text that I went over in the I got a lot
of texts were covering when I went over
in the slide portion so I'm gonna skip
over most of that but you've got
actually the code to generate for
instance that frog image of all the
frogs if you want it so everybody we can
we'd all download this simultaneously
because we're on Google servers not our
own local ones
now take a couple seconds
all right yeah so the first thing that
we're gonna do there's minimal pre-salt
pre-processing required which is the one
of the nice things that using a existing
data set the big thing that we're gonna
start out doing is scaling our images so
that they're they vary from negative 1
to 1 so those are just the pixel values
and I'll show you why that's important
later it'll be a lot more clear the
other thing I'm gonna do to set things
up is typically in Karis I don't know if
anybody has seen code that maybe you
would be used to sort of seeing like a
list of convolutional layers like this
and then like if you had like several of
them you might do that the I didn't do
that because we're gonna have like
several similarly instantiated
convolution layers and so we're gonna
use pythons funk tools to set that up
has anybody use that before oh yeah funk
tools are really really cool and so all
it does if you're not familiar it's not
a problem is it takes these parameters
and it just creams those into this
function and it calls the function so
it's like it's a great time-saver so all
of these we just have several lines of
comp 2d and then defining the same
number filters same kernel science
instead of writing that out every time
or copy pasting we can sort of write it
out like this and then now we have this
handy function ton that calls Kara's
layers comp 2d and fills it with all of
these parameters and that as you see
just a couple cells below makes our code
very very very clean so so yeah we're
gonna grab the number of classes from
our our why it's just gonna be 10 but if
we wanted to change this to size our 100
it would automatically update and then
we're gonna build this convolutional
network and so this is
building out if you haven't seen this
before this is this is Harris's lair
representation and it is literally
equivalent at least in general to this
representation of the slide that I
showed so you can see here now you get
the numbers on it that we're starting
out with a 32 by 32 image and we're
stringing it down to 16 by 16 the
information that we're learning is
actually it's drawing in these channels
or the feature maps sorry the features
we were talking about yes general I have
a blog post on this somewhere yeah
there's that's a really really good
question and I don't I don't want to
take too much time to talk about it but
the number one rule for like deep
learning tip that I can tell everybody
is start with something that exists and
works verbatim and then change it from
there that's like if I if anybody leaves
the room with like any advice like
that's at the top of my list and like
you can like like you could ask my
girlfriend like I spend so much time
tweaking this [ __ ] because there's like
so many parameters that it's like so
easy to get lost and like you might mess
up one parameter but you're changing
five and then it's now the rest of the
night that you're taking up to figure
out like which of those parameters is
the one and like what do you change it
to so if you just start out yeah with
something that exists and works and then
you can might change it piece by piece
scientifically a little bit and I say
that I say that with a little bit of
sarcasm because I personally fail to do
that so many times and yet this one this
is just one that I know that works i I
didn't it's not necessarily coming from
anywhere you can also
general patterns and so the one that I
was talking about at the beginning of
successively sort of shrinking the image
is really important and so that's all
we're doing here you you also see
another common attribute that you'll see
in the in the last notebook is that the
features typically increase as the size
of that image representation decreases
and that's so that the image can store
these a similar amount of information as
it processes through that network and so
here we're not doing that we're just
like setting the same number of filters
for every layer and so it's actually
like losing information capacity with
every layer which is fine this is a sort
of a toy model just to demonstrate it so
we installed PI dots so that we could
print these and this is just like a
different like visual way of looking at
that we get what's happening all right
I'm gonna set it up and I'm just gonna
use the defaults so I'm gonna use Adam
as that stochastic gradient descent
optimizer and I'm is just a like a
couple wrappers around vanilla SGD and
then if anybody's ever used scikit-learn
or anything like that we're literally
just gonna fit this like we built it
we've compiled it and then in one line
we're gonna fit it and so this is just
like all I'm doing right now is
reviewing like what it looks like to
build a convolutional classifier so this
is using that size of our data set maybe
like 20 years ago this is an extremely
challenging data set right now with like
a model that we could probably store
like in a couple megabytes we're gonna
eventually get up to like 80%
classification and again like the images
are just like a complete mess so it's
like really impressive to get at that
level of classification if we really
wanted to tune it we could get much much
higher yeah I love this one a little bit
I got running for 10 epochs but we don't
need to take all that time
oh yeah the other anything if anybody is
not used Karras I'll just point out a
couple just extremely handy parts of it
we're passing at this validation data
set and it's gonna automatically run its
it keeps track of our accuracy on the
training data as its training and then
it's automatically running the
validation at the end so that we can
compare it so we can see at the
beginning it's under fit it's gonna stay
under fit until sort of the very end
then we're gonna end up doing pretty
well I'll pause that I don't want it to
run too long I originally sort of made
as an exercise to add in layers to
improve it I don't want to take up too
much time on that but I'll leave that
you get the notebook so I'll leave that
to you at home you've also got like my
website and therefore email so if you
want the solutions you can email me but
I'm pretty sure you can figure it out
so here yeah this is again in text a lot
of what I said during the slide and so
you can see like this is the general
contour of a deep convolutional
classifier is starting out with this
input image in our case 32 by 32 oh I
didn't I usually remember zoom I know
what the three means like why we have
three initial channels
yes it's the initial color channels so
so that's what that's why we start out
and so we're essentially like taking
those three colour channels and
expanding them to 50 feature Maps and
they don't necessarily have anything to
do with color so yeah and this is that
general contour we can potentially add
be in things with batch normalization or
pooling or strides to eventually narrow
that down to like four by four and then
we at the very end we have a dense layer
for that oh my gosh oh this is the I
never edit in clab that's interesting
yeah this is that dense classification
vector that I talked about so it's gonna
be ten probabilities for each class yes
so to build the
let's well it's yeah let's see this is
where I generated the fraud a man just I
won't skip too far ahead yes so these
are just the programa just to give you
an idea of like the distribution so if
you want to turn that process around and
start with a vector and then generate an
image as an output it's essentially the
exact same process except now instead of
downsampling we're up sampling or we can
add a convolution transpose layer as
well so so in addition yeah I'm using
funk tools again to add a really nice
Leakey rail ooh I'll put a note there
yeah so the leaky rail ooh just instead
of the standard rail a which is flat
before zero the standard leaky Raymond
as a slight slope
[Music]
and so that's the only difference so
we're just like which is like in one
line just like defining this like useful
variant of gray blue and again this is
just so that we can actually preserve
that gradient in our discriminator and
so we're gonna build the discriminator
the same way this time I'm gonna add and
batch normalization in between but
otherwise it's the exact same the only
difference is that instead of a tin
class classification vector we have a
one class classification vector because
what are our two classes in this case in
the discriminators case yes exactly it's
a real or fake or our only two classes
that we care about and here you can
actually see for the generator exactly
that process that I talked about in the
slides so we have this first block to
take that input vector and then reshape
it into a like a convolutional shape so
4 by 4 by 50 we're gonna batch normalize
it and then up sample it and then now we
get into these convolutional layers as
also you can it'll be a little bit
easier to see when we print the
summaries so yeah you can sort of see
here that's it's going to the exact
opposite process where it's starting
with that vector and then building it up
to something exactly the same size as
our image trivia question I haven't
actually talked about this does anybody
know the range of output for tan h
negative 1 to 1 yes
so if we didn't know before that's
actually why at the very beginning I
scaled the images from negative 1 to 1
so we have an activation function that
easily maps on to that exact same range
and so that's the very last part of the
generator is just scaling it
appropriately yeah and so the the
important part about about this we're
actually gonna build these two models
the the very first one is the the
discriminator and that's quite easy we
just like taken an image
and then we're using binary
cross-entropy because it's a binary
classification
I put the discriminator we're gonna
combine the models but we're gonna use
the same thing it's gonna be the same
loss like the same output as the
discriminator so here you can see we're
actually taking in we're defining like
new layers here an input layer an image
layer and then we're actually passing
that through the discriminator model
here and so this is I sort of title the
talk caris plus tensor flow and the
reason is because like in secret right
here we're actually manipulating tensor
flow tensors and it's not it might not
be crystal clear but let me so yeah oh
that's a model let me build this I'll
show you you can see so if we run this
so what we're building here when we take
this like carrots input and then wrap
the generator around it and then get the
output of that the output image what
we're actually plugging into is a tensor
flow tensor and so all of this were
actually setting this up using tensor
flow just kind of behind the scenes but
yeah we can still do that we just need
to start with start with a Z and then
end up with that valid indicator and we
need those to connect and if you doubt
that they connect you can always see did
I call it plot model I believe I did
you can see what that looks like here
where we've got the noise the noise
input of a hundred dimensions we're
passing it through that sequential layer
which is our generator and then we're
passing that generator through our other
sequential layer which is a
discriminator cool and then now we
unlike before where we can use Karis as
handy like dot fit we're have to do this
a little bit by hand but the process is
not that tricky so I'll step through
these these lines of code really quickly
with you the first one like we asked how
do we generate similar are the same
images each time we do that by
generating the same set of random normal
vectors before we ever start training
and we just keep that so that's our
noise sample and we'll use that to
generate samples of noise periodically
I'll run this while I'm talking about it
o TQ TM does not work so yeah if you if
you're trying to run this and it doesn't
run you'll have to change this line this
line right here at the tqd msot QT m
notebook so my apologies for that but
but yes so we're generating this once
and then as we run through training
we're not regenerating again and that's
gonna let us sample images from the
generator as it improves we're gonna run
through several epochs I've got 10 to
start out but you can obviously change
that and then for each step inside of
that epoch we're gonna generate a new
set of indices for our examples and
we're to use that to build our batch of
our input data and then we're gonna
generate a batch of noise and that
changes everything we change it or train
it and then we're gonna generate an
image from the from the generator and so
that's these this is all gonna be our
input to the discriminator so we're
going to train the discriminator twice
each time around
once on the unvalidated
that's gonna be valid is just a list of
ones that I generated here and then
we're gonna generate it on fake and the
why for fake is just zeros so we've got
this X batch that's our training data
and we're saying like you need to guess
one for that and we've got the generated
data and we're saying you need to guess
0 for that and then yeah and so it's
it's a similar process but we just do it
once for the combined model for the
generator and the discriminator and we
for that one we just give it nose and
tell it whatever you produce with noise
you want to get the discriminator to
guess 1 and so what it outputs that's
going quite slowly interesting that must
be because we have a lot of there are a
lot of people aren't it's going quite a
bit quicker earlier today um yeah so if
you if you run this on your own time s
interesting it was going significantly
quicker um
yeah so I don't have much control over
how quickly this runs because it's
Google servers and not mine yeah if you
run this in the background it'll sort of
ill every 10 minutes I guess it'll start
sampling those and you can see it
improving quite a bit pretty quickly
alright the last thing I wanted to cover
really really quickly so if anybody
wants to experiment with the spectral
normalization layers and the auxilary
classifier i've got all that in this
notebook so i'm gonna skip ahead to
notebook 2 so so that's like the middle
of notebook is sort of very similar to
this one as well so yeah this is this is
the notebook that you'll need of you
when I get the data sets that I put
together it automatically downloads them
and ends up stem and it actually runs
pretty quickly
you also need to I've got a line in here
that requires an updated version of
Karis I'm going to run that as well so
while that's sort of cooking I'll talk a
little bit about some of the differences
here
the main difference here is that I have
this custom library that we actually
actually download from from here so we
can go ahead and look at that library so
yeah this is just standard Python code
where we are adding the spectral
normalization to convolution the 2d
convolution in Kerris and you can see
right here if you want to go through the
math if you want to tweak this at all
yourself you can but yeah all we're
doing here is we're actually going that
I just went through that special
normalization paper and then added added
this computation for every convolution
[Music]
alright and we can see that that worked
let me
all right yeah if you if you get an
error right on this block it's because I
expected you to download the soap hi in
the previous notebook so you might want
to run that from the previous notebook
if you get an error there but the really
important thing I wanted to show
everybody I guess there's two one is a
fairly new way in Kerris to load in data
from a data frame I mean that actually
is really helpful for the task of
multi-label classification and so that's
Karis has a data generator here and then
we're just passing it a data frame and
so this data frame is a list of all of
our images the file names of them and
then the attributes so whether people
have five book shadows or big lips or
wavy hair and and yeah we can so just
pass that directory and then this data
frame and then it automatically
generates batches for us from that and
we can look really quickly at the
architecture I built to get this to work
so here we got the discriminator it's
not that different you can see for these
like quite a bit more advanced layers
and the reason is like this spectral
normalization is hidden in that package
or that file that I had you download
otherwise it's essentially exactly the
same I'm also I'm using quite a bit
bigger filters so you can see here going
up from 50 to like 120 and from 120 down
to 50 instead of fixing it just at 50 so
the very different thing if you want to
do the auxilary classifier is happy how
you set up the models so I said we have
a combined model and that's this here
for the discriminating classifier so
this is the this is sort of the backbone
that we'll use for both of those and I
just called it discriminator base and
here's where we're gonna break that
apart and so you can see actually we're
defining two different layers one of
them is going to be a layer for
the binary classification of fake not
fake the other one is going to be for
the multi-label classification of all of
the Slav eight labels and so that's
that's the sort of newish modification
of the versatile auxilary can I'm using
a different loss here that we didn't
have too much time to go into but this
is this is a extremely like lightweight
implementation of hinge loss in Karis so
that's that's something I'd like to
write this up a little bit later because
all of the hinge loss examples online
are just way too complicated but you
really only need like ten lines here so
yeah once we define these two derivative
models and in our losses we can compile
all four of our models I'm so we have we
have four models in effect but we're
really just taking the discriminator and
training it first for the Gann task and
then for the classification task and
we're gonna do the same for the
generator we're gonna set up our
sampling data ahead of time so that we
don't have to resample each time and
then we're gonna run it and this is
probably gonna be slow too
but we'll see
but if it is we can just do questions
from now on I mean your questions loves
running oh yeah that's the initial okay
yeah
so while this is running let's let's
talk about questions that maybe we'll
get a couple batches and so we can see
it improving yeah that's a great
question no it doesn't have to be
symmetrical there's a few and there's a
few differences when we go up to this so
as you can see I sort of have a lot more
layers for the discriminator for one and
part of that's because for the
discriminator I'm breaking out the
activation whereas or actually I'm
adding batch normalization in the
discriminator and I'm not doing it
sorry I have better normalization here
in the generator I don't have it in the
discriminator and that's just like a
like a strange tweak that I found that
worked well I believe I would expect
that you could actually add batch
normalization here and it would work
fine typically you see like if you look
at the parameter counts this is at about
250,000 I generated was much much higher
it's well over double so they're
definitely not perfectly symmetrical and
then ends up being fine yeah that's a
good question
yeah in general you don't have to mix it
it typically is more work to mix it than
not there's a really really cool paper
slash like loss function developed by
I'll show you the paper
this woman Alexia JM I highly recommend
looking at it it actually explores Ganz
that look at the relative prediction
from true to false so it actually does
mix them and I think with typical loss
functions that doesn't provide an
improvement but she found a way to look
at rather than one and then the other
look at them relative to each other and
it actually works really well in some
cases so that's a good question
this is any other questions I think
somebody added pushing up here we might
get to one more yeah so you mentioned
that Ganz are much better than
autoencoders typically why do you think
that's the case in what if we consider
variation of other colors oh yeah that's
a great question so I'm gonna cop out of
that question by pulling up my favorite
textbook here or actually let me do the
Goodfellow tutorial because he's got a
great straightforward illustration of
that so the big difference is that arlen
coders are trained with what's called a
typically it's either mean square error
or mean average error and what happens
there we talked about modes earlier mode
collapse well you can imagine in an
autoencoder if there's two possibilities
so this is this is a images from a
network that was trying to predict from
one frame what the next wave would be so
if you imagine that you're an
autoencoder there might be a bunch of
different possibilities for that next
frame because you're tasked with
minimizing the squared error you're
always going to be better off if you
minimize the square error from like all
of them relative to their probability
and so you get this like blurry image
that's really like a composite of all
the possibilities adversarial because it
specifically tar
it's like whether or not something is
realistic or not it pushes the network
to produce plausible images rather than
like sort of something that minimizes
like the square error of what the
plausible images might be and so that's
one like that's one of the big
advantages you typically get like much
sharper images variational autoencoders
they're sort of a middle ground between
the two and I I really don't have like a
great explanation for why they haven't
been as successful as Ganz I know
Ian talks about them a lot in this
tutorial I'd like encourage you to look
that look into that and it might just be
that like we've like I actually I'm not
even speculate like I don't have a good
answer about why they just haven't yeah
I actually started working with the AES
like before Ganz a while ago and
couldn't get them to do anything useful
so as a good question yeah any other
questions we got a couple minutes cool
well we can see the first this is like
not a fully bug this is the first half
epoch and these things are a little bit
cloudy but this is like where it's
starting to learn these spaces and you
can sort of it's gonna be it about the
second quarter epoch in a little bit all
right well if that's like if that's all
the questions we can just like sit
around and watch this bake and then like
thanks for it wasn't amazing to talk
[Applause]